aim Ross has been banned from twitch for
the eighth time but this one's permanent
and the streamers campaigned to promote
rival streaming site kick has reached a
whole new level I literally promote kick
every [__] day Dad get me out of here
hey guys before I get into the video
just wanted to remind you that liking
and subscribing does help the channel so
if you want to see more stuff in this
vein as well as you know Esports and
gaming feel free to support us by
subscribing the channel ringing the
notification Bell or dropping a like on
the video Aiden Ross has been having a
hell of a couple weeks after claiming
that twitch was silencing him Aiden made
his debut on Kik a rival streaming
platform and on his first day he
streamed the NFL Super Bowl to a ton of
people since then I think it's fair to
say that in Ross has been acting a
little erratically for one he streamed
porn to his Kik audience definitely a
weird move from someone who claims to be
opposed to pornography what do y'all
want to watch bro I don't support porn
like I don't I don't support
yeah I want to watch on here bro I don't
support the [__] I don't condone it I
don't support it and when Jake lucky
pointed this out on Twitter Aiden sent
him a very unhinged message that can I
think be charitably interpreted as a
threat Aiden signed with kick this past
Thursday and while the announcement
didn't say that the deal was exclusive
it seems like it's probably his home for
the short term at least since he was
banned from twitch on Sunday for a while
the exact reason was unclear and as
Aiden puts it there was no reason at all
I'm permanently man on Twitch it's done
it's already done
but I got permanently banned for no
reason but a report by desereto on
Monday cites a twitch spokesperson who
said that per our community guidelines
unmoderated hateful conduct in chat such
as racist and anti-semitic messages is
not allowed on Twitch others pointed to
Aiden speaking with Nick Fuentes a
self-described white nationalist who has
denied the Holocaust only thing is I
don't think that this happened on Twitch
so I'm not sure now if you watched my
last video you might remember that I
kind of mused about how maybe Aiden
really was trying to get permaband in
this whole situation now that we have
his response I feel like it kind of
gives the game away a little bit in the
response he jokes about how twitch
banned him on National hate Jewish
people day before going into an even
more unserious argument which is that if
he had blue hair and makeup then for
some reason twitch wouldn't have banned
him I'm not even a bash twitch
completely
but the one thing I'll say is this
if I have blue hair and did my makeup
would you a Bambi twitch because without
twitch I'm about who I am today
and you guys maybe sign a a
multi-millionaire million dollar deal on
Kik which which is freedom of speech and
I could say and do whatever I want
without suffering crazy consequences
such as losing my platform and my voice
I'm allowed to sound voted for Donald
Trump without you guys freaking the [__]
out and saying Badness racist but on
Tuesday evening Ross train wreck and
Jake lucky spoke about the situation on
Ross's kick stream and while it didn't
clarify really any of these strange
statements we did learn some additional
things about what's been happening
firstly Ross apologized to his audience
for showing them pornography and said
that he needed to do better that's
something that I told myself I gotta be
better and I gotta be a better leader
and train wreck confirmed that yeah this
isn't allowed on the platform the line
is porn though so porn is banned right
nudity band hate speech band a lot of
people think freedom of speech is hate
speech it is not these are all bannable
your accounts will get banned once you
get a moderation and partnership team in
place once we get people to be viewing
chat all the time listen L me all you
want but there is a difference between
freedom of speech and hate speech and
hate speech will not be tolerated so
Ross's video was published before the
desereto report that I mentioned but at
the end of the day it doesn't really
matter because Ross's video doesn't
actually give us any clarity as to the
reasoning behind it but now that it's
his new home we should ask what's going
on with this whole kick situation
because if kick didn't exist you could
imagine a world where Aiden Ross
definitely needs to stay unbanned on
Twitch but we don't live in that world
we live in Kik world now and in Kik
world it's possible to sign a pretty big
deal with another streaming company that
isn't Twitch in fact during that Jake
lucky discussion that I mentioned Ross
said that it was apparently the biggest
deal ever I'll just tell you straight up
um I just signed the biggest streaming
deal of all time out of any Creator as
far as I know and it feels amazing I'm
blessed bro and now I just want to take
time to really capitalize off that and
give back to people and give back to
people who are needed and blessed out of
everyone I can still running a streaming
site isn't exactly like running a
lemonade stand it costs a lot of money
you might recall when the whole argument
over streamer splits was happening
twitch pointed to a monthly cost of
about one thousand dollars for a 200 an
hour a month streamer with 100
concurrent users but we're talking about
a lot more users on kickstreams for
people like Aiden Ross and he's recently
claimed that streamers I show speed
Bruce and Kai sanat will be following
him if that's true then kicks bills are
about to go up while the Tuesday stream
did not come firm that any of these
names have signed with Kik it did hint
that future signings are in the works
now when it comes to streaming I really
doubt that Kik is getting a favorable
rate like twitch probably is since
they're owned by Amazon but on top of
that let's remember Kik gives a far more
favorable percentage of subscriptions to
the streamer so how is kick paying for
this the honest answer is we don't know
exactly how but we do know that there
are links between the ownership of Kik
and the ownership of stake the crypto
Casino site that was everywhere on
Twitch before the unregulated crypto
casinos were banned gambling is popular
on Kick sure and apparently there are
people who own parts of Kik who own
parts of stakes so maybe that
Arrangement is kind of worth it to those
people but again how do they do this
without advertisers it's just so
difficult to imagine and herein lies the
issue who wants to advertise on Kik
we've already talked about some of the
extreme extremely Advertiser unfriendly
things that have been streamed on the
site Austin Ox who works as Hassan's
video editor kindly compiled a Twitter
thread of just some of the outrageous
stuff that's happened on Kik recently
content no sane Advertiser would want to
touch some of it I can't even really
show here we're talking sex robots
public harassment somebody who
definitely sounded like a minor reacting
to pornography and somebody just
receiving oral sex on stream and yeah
kik does have a TOS it just seems like
maybe it isn't possible or maybe even
desirable for it to enforce it
thoroughly right now by the way that
last streamer heal Mike got a one day
ban he also really likes typing and
putting like a bald eagle emote which I
I don't know I think it's actually
pretty funny I like it it's a good
gimmick so advertising kind of seems out
too sure train wreck who says he's an
advisor to kick has been forced to act
as the voice of reason but he's walking
a tightrope and sometimes he's also
seemed pretty lenient like lenient
enough that pulling a stunt like this
and eating a one day ban is probably
just worth it for some people in the
interview with Jake lucky train
criticized twitch for a lot of things
and I found some of those criticisms
interesting and some of them even valid
at this point twitch has been on top of
the Heap for a while and that means
they've controlled people's livelihoods
so if they just take your livelihood
away without explanation that could feel
pretty bad I don't view the impulse to
keep a clean image as conspiratorially
as train seems to I wager it's just what
advertising focused businesses want it's
a structural thing and I love rooting
for the underdog and it seems like there
are success stories on Kik and I don't
want to downplay that either kick is
potentially more competition for twitch
and that's good not only for the
streamers who suddenly have an option
besides accepting whatever twitch and
YouTube allow but also for the industry
more generally if this thing is just
five crypto casinos in a trench coat
it's really hard to see it eventually
rivaling twitch and I'm not sure I'd
even want it to I have serious concerns
about content moderation on the platform
as it stands and standards exist for a
reason hell even train accepted this in
the interview with lucky but at the same
time I have to admit I'm intrigued by
the platform's evolving approach siding
with streamers in terms of sub revenue
is a great start and I'm willing to bet
there are plenty of people who would
like to try something that just isn't
twitch again there are plenty of
questions and it's not clear that the
niche here is necessarily the biggest
but the one thing I'm pretty sure of is
however it goes down it's going to be
worth watching
thank you